la première vague avait pas besoin de
confiner toute la france il y avait des
hauts de france l'île de france et le
grand test
nous on a confiné toute la france bon
donc là on peut ne pas leur reprocher on
peut dire c'était on n'était pas habitué
on n'est pas comme les coréens
on n'a pas eu les épidémies d'avant donc
on n'est pas bon puis on continue à être
pas bon un sur les tests on a été
catastrophique malgré malgré ce que
disaient certains épidémiologistes
alors ça crée une défiance est encore le
président on va voir didier rahout à
marseille
qu'est-ce qui fait 1 il va voir il se
déplace lui même pour aller voir
quelqu'un qui a beaucoup de talent qui
est un grand talent de communication
mais qui est sorti des clous de la
communication scientifique de la rigueur
scientifique
alors pourquoi il nomme un comité
scientifique pour aller voir didier
rahout failli fais de la politique je
m'excuse politicienne comme on fait un
centre de députés qui ont pris fait et
cause pour la dirai aux dioxines
chloroquine qui n'y connaissent rien bon
donc le pays est dans un état de
défiance maintenant tout le monde
accepte pour remonter tout le monde va
accepter ce couvre-feu qui fait des
dégâts
alors oui la culture c'est évidemment un
secteur économique
mais c'est d'abord un secteur de comme
vous le dis j'ai très bien madame
l'ancien maire un secteur qui est
indispensable à la santé mentale d'une
population à vie intellectuelle d'une
population les médecins ne sont pas tous
omnibulée seulement par la santé
physique mais quand tu as pu santé
physique et la c puis on peut pas
laisser non plus aux jeunes l'idée ben
c'est à cause de toi que papy et mamie
sont morts bas c'est un peu dommage mais
en fait c'est pas grave tu as vécu non
personne ne pense à les jeunes sont
prêts absolument écouter les jeunes
étudiants en médecine les jeunes élèves
infirmiers ont été absolument admirable
cette glu générationnel de l'année
correspond à rien il ya ceux qui font
n'importe quoi
puis à ceux qui sont au contraire très
altruiste qui se mobilisent n'y a qu'à
voir y compris médecins du monde
médecins sans frontières chez les jeunes
sa une une attirance forte donc ya pas
un problème vraiment de génération y
avait un problème politique de santé
publique
[Musique]